comme presque tous les vendredis depuis
le début des vacances le service
jeunesse et vie de quartier de la mairie
des clayes-sous-bois propose à ses
habitants des animations au sein des
quartiers de la ville ce vendredi 30
juillet c'était à la résidence du moulin
vert aujourd'hui à différentes activités
qui sont proposées on a toujours un
bilan qu'un espace pour les enfants pour
les bébés les enfants les en bas âge
pour soulager un peu les mamans le temps
de le temps qu'ils puissent profiter
éventuellement d'autres activités comme
aujourd'hui on a un massage thaïlandais
est proposé gratuitement pour les buts
pour les gens du quartier
autres animations proposées des chasses
aux trésors de la sensibilisation à
l'écologie ou encore la découverte
d'instruments de musique
l'objectif c'est déjà de créer des
animations pour les gens qui ont du mal
à partir en vacances et pour pouvoir
être au plus près de la population pour
pouvoir aussi prendre un peu le pouldu
des quartiers prendre un petit peu leurs
attentes pour l'année de l'année à venir
prochain rendez vous les 20 et 27 août
au programme un spectacle de feu en
déambulation et le 27 août un cinéma en
plein air toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur le site de la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois